mexi man and she says mercer's just sour
about die hard 3 because he played bruce
willis stunt double for the sandwich
board scene
and he refused payment because he says
the work is its own reward
is that true mike sure sometimes you
just do things for the joy of it
the work is its own reward sometimes you
just sometimes doing what you love
is all you need well mike you know what
i love
movies about empowered women i wanted to
show you this trailer because i know you
you know the problem about movies with
empowered women
not enough of them so you're saying
there's a new one
good i'm so excited
mike i love you you don't sound it i
love movies about empowered intelligent
women because they have to exist
somewhere
what's your favorite movie about
empowered women mind showgirls
set it off where four black women rob a
bank because that's literally their best
option in life
mine has saved the last dance why
because she has life is so bad that she
has to go dance with the book
oh no you know what actually my favorite
uh my favorite empowered woman
movie is she's all that uh the movie
about how
uh a woman needed a man to fix her and
make her cool and pretty well
that's that's a very good one um
my favorite empowered woman is scarface
uh
because she shall fight for her
stupid dance she even bothered to learn
it
that's how much nobody gave a [ __ ] about
that movie is that
she didn't bother to learn how to dance
pacino didn't bother to learn to do a
cuban accent just nobody cared about
that movie
i'm kidding my favorite empowered movie
is uh
it's kill bill because even with all the
other heroin stuff the only thing you
can think about is her toes and how much
quentin tarantino want to look at them
i like to kill bill though you know why
because most of the people that she beat
up were other women
that was fair well that's real well i
know but you know she had to cheat with
bill
that's true she had to do the the
magical uh what was it the made up move
[ __ ] five pressed punch that made
your heart explode after two steps or
whatever that [ __ ] was
somebody says their favorite is two
girls one cup okay
um somebody's not pissing me off saying
pacino's accent was actually really good
in scarf i don't even
[ __ ] kill like luckily they had
stephen bauer in it
stephen bauer was the only thing that
gave a level of realism to the
cuban-ness of that movie
and then the rest was like robert loggia
going like
oh come on tony over here oh we're gonna
sell cocaine tony
why is robert logia why did they put
bronzer on robert loggia and go
ah you're cuban
um
let's um sorry i'm sorry ladies sorry
hey this one's called
promising young woman okay i would also
it's going to be released
internationally is who gives a [ __ ]
check it out what are you going to
i do know yeah
another movie that's going to make me
know but they're making these movies
about things that aren't
real problems in 2020 like in college
they went to the college thing right
like
for the most part it's the other way
around how many how many stories have we
read of men being kicked out and it
turns out the woman was lying like
men don't get the benefit of the doubt
it's like a zero policy for that
well i agree but at the same time it's
not like it's just based on a true story
it is we
write movies about you know caped
superheroes and
space people and [ __ ] wormholes and
[ __ ] you know what i mean i mean it's a
work of fiction
i get it but it it's not so much that
they make these kinds of movies because
um you're allowed to have works of
fiction but
my but my issue is that they make so
many of these movies that they're almost
trying to astroturf people
and gaslight people into thinking this
is an everyday occurrence it has a
90 positive rating on rotten tomatoes
critics
uh review based on 50 reviews average
rating of 7.3
uh yeah it's critics yes yeah so that
doesn't i'm not talking about them
let's see what the actual reviews are
when those come out
i think they are out i think this movie
might already be out
let's see rotten tomatoes let's let's
check it out
ron tomatoes uh let's see search
pretty young what is it promising young
woman
promising young woman
90 fresh there is no audience score yet
oh you're right it doesn't come out in
theaters until the 25th so
that's why critics have seen it let's
wait for the audience score you think
it's going to be good
i think it's going to probably get
trashed well you know who i don't want
to hear talking about it
elliott page yeah i know sit down i
i don't need that white man talking
about this because this
isn't your problem i'm just happy for
chelsea handler she got a movie and i
think that's cool
that's not chelsea handler it might as
well be yeah it's the same thing you're
right